okay let's do this it's your boy
psychobabble and we are currently doing
the mission find color 12 Christine stay
this [ __ ] swallowed something bad taste
like why chef I've got your [ __ ]
[ __ ] and with that guy got are you just
[ __ ] run away
tough [ __ ] is this way I get good [ __ ] a
ghost harvester hate to say you [ __ ]
a conscious West oh [ __ ]
I like no [ __ ] healthier
okay didn't think much of our chance
it'd why is it I suppose what we're
scrape some cloud residue there's
electric hot plate although I ok let's
go let's go where the hell did you get
this one hairy cow clueless calm
speakers of age poorly like the modern
pre-war junk the speakers are knitted
signal that'll start off your collar if
you stay too long there are damaged
speakers and shielded once the damaged
ones you can destroy it range don't get
close you can't switch them off like a
radio ok where is master but did he go
away dog will be good this time shut I
hate that [ __ ] that's what I've no
[ __ ] ammo
ok I got no ammo
picking up an emitter signature watch
for security homographs dangerous don't
use them attacking them is useless step
back
Oh
come on come on whole body whole body
[ __ ] a
I wasn't slamming like her eyes I it's
like home please come out
can't fix it the end the hall red light
means this shield must be where to shove
them off somewhere else please come out
is that the shield speakers
food yes Connie just that bastard okay
always yelling can be passed an alcohol
red light means to shoot maybe where I
shove them off somewhere else
she says wait Harris template all right
come on I need some [ __ ] help
that really needs [ __ ] hell
ok
okay I got the basement k don't like
this place want to go back back to the
base what it's slamming
oops
[ __ ] gotta live there we go it could
be the second floor I can't get your gun
okay
the [ __ ] is this they eat him let's go
now people missing heads can fit state
coming here big dog hungry just the [ __ ]
up dog be a man
Jesus
Jack I'm a run for it fairy guy here we
go
I shut my goodbyes
[ __ ] a
Harry has the fog embraced by chase s
I know is I need some [ __ ] out
yeah Bess
hello
thanks for watching
you